you tweet a lot
i use my tweets to express myself
some people use their hair i use twitter
well but you use your tweeting to to
kind of get back at critics
rarely you kind of have little wars with
the press twitter is a war zone if
somebody's gonna jump in the war zone
it's like okay you're in the arena let's
go yeah i mean otherwise it's uh hello
first amendment like premium speech is
fundamental but but how do they know if
it's gonna move the market if they're
not reading all of them
before you send them so i guess we might
make some mistakes
who knows
are you serious
that was perfect
you're doing your radicals i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message it is monday april 18th in the
year 20 22 and that was noted
internet extremist
elon musk on 60 minutes a couple years
ago
being remarkably consistent about what
he believes and why he believes it and
that is going to be the theme of the
show today because you know
ladies and gentlemen we are in what i
have called the post woke world it is
here you just have to see it and
strengthen it it's on the way it's
coming yes the woke world still exists
and those wokesters are going to keep
destroying what whatever is left of the
old world but a new post woke world is
being built right now before we get to
it i just want to say that i hope you
all had a wonderful easter and passover
holiday i have to say you know we did we
went up to jersey to my aunts and uncles
with my folks and cousins and a lot of
kids and aunts and uncles and everybody
else and uh we read the the passover
seder as i've done for my entire life 45
years on earth two times a year that's
about 90 times and i have to say i
probably found it more meaningful this
year than any other year you know the
story of man's eternal quest for freedom
i really it was really hitting me like
oh that has a little something to do
perhaps with why i believe the things i
believe and why i fight for the things i
believe in every day on this show there
was a particular passage
in the seder that i took a picture of
i'll post it i actually did post it in
the locals community uh if you want to
take a look at reubenreport.locals.com
just all about freedom and man's desire
to find freedom wherever it is and and
yearning for liberty and freedom and all
of these things um
and and the other piece that was really
interesting to me this past uh seder uh
was that
it means
it makes more sense a story
about a bunch of hebrews going through
the desert for 40 years and getting mana
from heaven
and dealing with 10 plagues and the
pharaoh and splitting the red sea and
all this stuff it actually made more
sense than anything going on in our
secular world today what does that tell
you like we're we're living in a world
where they tell us boys or girls and
girls or boys and non-racists are racist
two plus two is five blah blah blah all
the usual insanity that is just like
thought of as normalcy
right
and now i'm reading this 5 000 year old
story right this story that people have
been telling for a long long time that
sounds like it's of these crazy things
frogs are falling out of the sky fire
and murray killing of the first sun the
freaking
the river is splitting and it was making
more sense i think this may be something
there i suspect that some of you had
similar experiences whether it was a
passover seder or whether it was at
church during easter but regardless and
whether you believe that stuff literally
or figuratively or anything else hope
you had a great weekend i'm feeling very
refreshed and by the way the big tour
it is starting this week yeah that's
right tomorrow night the don't burn this
country book tour kicks off in west palm
beach with don jr there's a couple
tickets left for that one benny johnson
and clearwater the next night the next
night after that andrew clavin in
raleigh north carolina then after that a
lot of shows in a row michael malus in
atlanta then janmi park in chicago glenn
back in dallas megan mccain in dc megan
kelly in west niagara new york dennis
prager and brea california larry elder
in oxnard dennis douglas murray in san
jose blake masters and charlie kirk in
phoenix arizona brian callan in denver
and then finally and this is uh
important to note on january 2nd the
orlando show no i'm sorry on june 2nd
june 2nd
the orlando show has been rescheduled it
was supposed to be tonight we had a
major guest a big timer
i'm talking top of the list guest
couldn't do it tonight so we decided to
move it i can't publicly announce who it
is just yet but it's happening i assure
you we have all the clearances the
things have been signed i can announce
the guest on may 2nd
but the show is on
june 2nd and you can buy tickets for all
of the shows right now at daverubin.com
events okay so today's show
the theme is about how to create that
post-woke world how to let go of all of
the nonsense that these people have
thrust upon us
and how to actually start building the
new world and that guy elon musk who i
just showed you in the cold open he is
leading it he is saying i will fight the
entire freaking system and the entire
freaking system you know what it's doing
tim the ridiculous hit pieces in
business insider and in bloomberg and
washington post and the scary mean elon
musk is coming for free speech the guy
trying to defend free speech he's coming
for free speech because they will have
you believing that up is down and left
is right and good is bad but he is one
man
with extraordinary means but he is still
one man and he is standing up against
that machine and i think that's the
model that we've been looking for so the
theme today is how do you stand up
because we have a chance but it's on you
good people before we talk to you about
that though i want to talk to you about
meat and pork and other meaty such
things uh did you know that 60 of us
pork production comes from one company
owned by the chinese and their hogs are
given something called rack dopamine
which is banned in 160 countries
including china yet you'll find it in
your grocery aisle every day there's a
better way i'd like to tell you guys
about moiq that's moo plus oink i've got
some in my freezer right now moist
delivers grass-fed and grass-finished
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
and sustainable wild caught alaskan
salmon straight to your door more ink
farmers like more
wink farmers farm like our grandparents
did and as a result moiq meat tastes
like it should because the family farm
does it better the moic difference is a
difference you can taste and you could
feel good knowing you're helping family
farms stay financially independent as
well you choose the meat delivered in
every box like ribeyes to chicken
breasts to pork chops to salmon fillets
and much more plus you can cancel any
time
i've gotten a whole bunch of bone in rib
eyes and i've got pretty much everything
i got salmon i got all kinds of stuff
shark tank host kevin o'leary called
moiq's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and ring doorbell founder jamie
simenoff jumped at the chance to invest
in moic plus they guarantee you'll say
oink oink i'm just so happy i got
boinked keep american farming by going
up and signing up at moynkbox.com
reuben right now and listeners of this
show get free filet mignon in every
order for a year that's one year of the
best filet mignon you'll ever taste but
for a limited time spelled m o i n k box
dot com slash reuben that's mikebox.com
ruben okay so let's dive into this elon
musk twitter situation a little bit
further and again i want to stress all
of this because this story ain't going
away for a while and it shouldn't and i
pray to the lord that it has a good
resolution that it is not vital that
you're on twitter and i admire a lot of
you that are not on twitter and you're
probably happier for not being on
twitter however
twitter in essence right now is the
public square the way all of our
politicians all of our taste makers all
of our culturally relevant people
communicate with each other and then get
ideas out to people
is through twitter now that may be evil
that may be wrong twitter may be
screwing us screwing with us in all
sorts of ways and it likely is
but it exists as that thing right now
and elon musk is simply coming in and
saying i would like to clean it up i
would like it to be a little more
respectful of free speech so he just did
a ted talk he was part of a ted talk
over the last couple days and he was
asked why does he want to buy twitter
you want to pay out 40 or whatever it is
billion dollars in cash you you'd like
them to come come with you in in yeah
it's i mean i mean i could technically
afford it um
i i had that i had that um but but but
but it's but um what i'm saying is this
this is
this is a this is not a
way to sort of make money
you know i think this is it's just that
i think this is um
this could
my
strong intuitive sense is that uh having
a public platform that is maximally
trusted
um and and and
and broadly inclusive
um
is extremely important to the future of
civilization but you've described
yourself i don't care about the
economics at all
[Applause]
that's pretty great and you know i
always say this thing about when
someone's telling the truth you can kind
of feel it you know even though he a
little bit fumbled through what he said
there the the two phrases that were
pretty beautiful
he wants something to be maximally
trusted now think about that phrase for
just a second we have almost no trust in
any of our institutions right now nobody
turns on the news and trusts the news
the information that you get if you go
to college is largely
filtered through leftist ideology we all
know that there's so few people that are
trusted we don't even have say
what we had 10 years ago of things that
should be somewhat apolitical that we
all kind of agreed we sort of liked
oprah was sort of generally liked by
people david letterman was generally
liked by people we don't have anything
that's sort of commonly bringing us
together and roughly trusted even if you
disagree with the politics of it so
maximally trusted great phrase and then
he said broadly inclusive so what does
he mean by that broadly inclusive that
roughly we'll try to get as many ideas
on here as possible and treat them
equally i'm adding that part secondly
but i think that's really what he means
by broadly that we're going to get ideas
on here and we're not going to be
censoring people that's what we want and
then of course what that is all couched
in
is this idea that he's saying this this
isn't about money
he's got the money he says he's got the
money it's a lot of cash and he's got it
but he's not doing this for financial
purposes and how do you know he's not
doing it for financial purposes because
if he was well first off there's not a
lot of money to be made at twitter
twitter doesn't seem to be making a lot
of money the stock of twitter is
basically valued at exactly what it was
valued at when it went publicly in 2013
that's not what a successful public
company does you want a public company
to go up like a hockey stick right you
want to see this incredible growth
incredible revenue all of the
distribution all of this stuff going up
so that the shareholders are making more
money so the company becomes more
successful starts acquiring other
companies maybe goes into other avenues
all sorts of things it's not doing any
of those things however it does have a
death grip on our ability to communicate
with each other so he's saying this is
not really a business thing that i'm
doing i think for a vital functioning
democracy which i would like to live in
which i would like my kids to live in a
world that has these things i am willing
to do this
well then he continued and talked about
some real life consequences related to
all this
and a good sign as to whether there's
free speech is
is
is someone you
don't like allowed to say something you
don't like
and if that is the case then we have
free speech and it's it's damn annoying
when someone you don't like says
something you don't like
that is a sign of a healthy functioning
uh
free speech situation
think about how they are trying to frame
him as the bad guy right now
saturday night live which is a former
comedy show which is just pure corporate
trash right now uh they did a joke this
past weekend i obviously don't watch
saturday i don't even have cable i
wouldn't even know how to get the
channel anymore um
but they did a joke this week that he's
basically buying twitter because he's a
white guy and he wants to be able to say
the n-word that that's what corporate
press is telling you about this guy
here's the guy saying hey i want to buy
this thing i know it's not a great
business decision
and it'll harm my bottom line but i want
to do it so that people can say mean
things about me online do you think he's
going to suddenly start banning people
who say mean things about him of course
not absolutely of course not that is not
going to be the case so that is just
going to continue so i thought
why don't we pause here for a moment and
go back to some of really what is going
on here those real life consequences
that you want people to be able to say
controversial things you want people to
be able to say things that stir the pot
a little bit
now again we're not talking about the
things that are direct violations of the
law you don't want people to pay people
to be able to make terrorist threats
okay we have very strict laws around
libel and slander but that's pretty much
it okay
but you do want people to be able to say
controversial things especially in
controversial times and i'll give you a
very personal example of this as you
guys know back in july of last year
i was suspended on twitter because i
said that vaccine mandates were coming
fox news actually wrote about it so
here's a little bit from fox news they
said ruben landed in hot water uh with
the social media platform on thursday
night when he tweeted a response to the
biden administration's evolving reaction
to the pandemic now here is what my
tweet was they want a federal vaccine
mandate for vaccines which are clearly
not working as promised just weeks ago
people are getting and transmitting
kovid despite the facts plus now they're
prepping us for booster shots a sane
society would take pause we do not live
in a sane society ruben tweeted thursday
evening okay so i want you just to think
about that for a second so this is back
in july before the mandates before the
booster shots and all that when it was
just leaking out that the vaccines were
not working as promised and all i did
was listen to the information and tweet
something that was fairly obvious to me
that's what i did and i was suspended
for that i had to delete the tweet
eventually because i'm up
i guess i have some level of influence i
was getting i was able to get enough
people to tweet about it that they they
said it was a mistake and they retracted
it but here's the here's the thing that
they sent me i think we've got that they
forced me to delete it so you have to
actually delete it otherwise you can't
get back into your account
and i think we've got some
images here from washington post and a
few of the other uh
places of journalism
where they were basically admitting that
i was right an american tragedy biden
offers incentives and mandates to get 90
million holdouts to vaccinate covet 19
updates cnn pfizer data suggests third
dose of covet 19 vaccine strongly boosts
protection against delta variant you can
you can just roll through them i don't
have to read all of them but you guys
see the idea that basically all i did
was say something that was true a little
bit in advance and that i was suspended
for that there's plenty of other people
say donald trump
say tucker carlson say charlie kirk say
the babylon be etc etc that are
suspended on twitter right at this very
minute for basically saying that boys
are not girls and girls are not boys so
i don't mean to make this about me but
i'm just trying to give you an example
of just i'm just some guy elon is just
some guy that
we are sort of all fighting for the same
thing here if you're fighting for
anything
related to truth
now i thought why don't we go back a
little bit further and see how they've
confused and lied
and applied pressure on us in crazy ways
so here's a throwback to fouchy and
mandates and
airplanes and a bunch more well i think
the president is is you know being
somewhat moderate in his demand if you
want to call it that in that there are
some people who really don't want to get
vaccinated but they don't want to lose
their job you got to give them an off
lane and the offlane is if you get
tested frequently enough and find out
you're positive you won't come to work
and you won't infect other people so it
really is somewhat of a compromise there
myself i would make it just vaccinate or
not but he was trying to be moderate in
what his pronouncement was
should we have a vaccine mandate for
domestic travel air travel
[Music]
you know
chuck i'm i'm not going to make any any
pronouncements about what we should have
about vaccine mandates for travel we
know that we evaluate these things
literally in real time all the time you
know everything is discussed and
everything is on the table so i always
tell you guys it's important not to
forget what they were saying all the way
back then so he was telling us that
biden was being moderate because okay
fine you don't have to be vaccinated but
you should have to be tested every day
at work if you go in he would force
everybody so he's actually saying i
would be far worse than joe biden but
joe biden's being okay
except we know then that joe biden was
trying to scare the f out of everyone
when it came to vaccines firing all the
front-line workers telling us about the
winter of death etc etc and you may
remember this when ted cruz uh basically
did a really nice job recapping how
biden was trying to destroy the lives of
decent people who were just trying to
make a medical decision for themselves
and their families
we've seen joe biden
implementing illegal and
unconstitutional vaccine mandates
standing up
and firing soldiers and sailors and
airmen and marines advocating that
doctors be fired that nurses be fired
that police officers be fired that
firefighters be fired
that airline captains and flight
attendants be fired
remember when we were firing the people
we said were the most important the
essential workers the people who were
keeping law and order the people who
were making sure people were healthy et
cetera et cetera and then we started
firing all of them remember when we did
that
yeah that's who'd that come from that
came from joe biden that came from
anthony fauci it didn't come from ted
cruz okay that's what they did but of
course they went after everybody and
you'll see how i think you're in case
you're not fully playing along you'll
see you'll see how i'm linking this to
the elon thing that the machine starts
coming for you if you say something true
you may have heard of this joe rogan guy
remember that month
well it was about i was about a month
and a half ago about six weeks ago where
we had a four day
binge where the entire machine kept
telling us all that joe rogan was a
racist
they didn't have any evidence that joe
rogan was a racist but they had found
him saying the n word usually quoting
other people or making fun of people who
say the n-word and it was oddly
it all happened right after
he had dr robert malone uh one of the
inventors of the mrna vax on his show
what is likely to have been the tweet
that triggered this and you know you
never know
the last two that i can think of that
went out was one that was on our sub
stack
in which we um referred to a fantastic
video that has been put out by the
canadian covet care alliance group that
summarizes all the malfeasance and data
manipulation misinterpretation
associated with the pfizer vaccines and
their clinical trials it's a super video
and um of course that's
i guess that is uh interpreted as
something that would cause people to
become vaccine hesitant that's the sin
in general is saying things that cause
people to become vaccine hesitant
the other thing that i put out
immediately before that
was a post a link
to a website for the world economic
forum
that lays out their entire strategy
for how they manage media how they're
managing covet 19
and all of their core messaging it's a
fascinating website with links
those are the only two things i can
think of
that would meet the criteria
okay so that is dr robert malone who has
a ton of patents on mrna technology he's
one of the fathers of the technology
when he made that appearance on the joe
rogan show he was already suspended by
twitter for as michael just told me 19
violations related to covet
misinformation one of the most
respected highest level experts in mrna
technology was suspended by twitter now
who at twitter made that decision do
they have scientists
on staff that are making these decisions
or could these have been political
decisions are these things related to
the government does this have anything
to do with the same type of people that
might not want you knowing about the
hunter biden laptop oh lordy lordy am i
saying too many true things at once this
can't end well
do we have a bunker around here by the
way we need a bunker we're gonna get we
have a bunker no we're gonna florida you
can't have under you can't have
basements we've got to figure out
something um
but you get the point he was already
suspended by twitter when he did that
show then he goes on the joe rogan show
and then literally what happens about
three days after that the entire machine
you remember those four days we had to
cover it extensively here starts telling
you that joe rogan's a racist that joe
rogan's show should be kicked off
spotify brian stelter is doing all these
things on cnn about you know joe rogan
ushers people into the alt-right and all
the rest of the nonsense
ah but what am i always trying for on
this show solutions so what is the
solution
elon musk was there a question
why why make that offer oh so
um
well i think it's very important for
uh there to be
an inclusive arena for
free speech uh where
all yeah so uh yeah
um
twitter has become kind of the de facto
town square um so
uh
it's just really important that people
have the both the uh the reality and the
perception
uh that they're able to speak freely
within the bounds of the law um
and
you know so one of the things that i
believe twitter should do is open source
the algorithm
um and make any changes
uh to people's tweets you know if
they're emphasized or de-emphasized uh
that action should be
made apparent so you can anyone can see
that that action has been taken so
there's no sort of behind the scenes um
manipulation either algorithmically or
manually
guys really get it into your pores this
is the guy that the machine is now
telling you is evil this is the guy that
the corporate press is now telling you
is the bad guy the guy who is saying oh
there should be more transparency there
should be more honesty there should be
more voices there should be a more even
playing field and this is exactly the
same as to what they did to joe rogan a
month and a half ago because he was
willing to have conversations with
basically the world's foremost expert on
the mrna technology so i'm trying to
show you how the machine
operates around people that are trying
to just
have an honest conversation
just have a a place to talk where
there's a little messiness on the
fringes where we can think for ourselves
and figuring things out but there is an
entire superstructure that exists the
corporate press to make sure that you
cannot see that
and oh do we have an example and this is
where i do we have the warning can we
throw the warning up is it a little late
for we've got the warning the content
advisory what you're about to see is
pure [ __ ] we have to put that up
before we put on these people over at
msnbc this is the mental institution
pretending to be a news network this is
joy reid she is a racist
psychotic american-hating lunatic but
she found a guest that's even worse than
her here you go so look at musk musk
has built his business through
government subsidies years ago and now
turns around stiffs the government on
taxes and and explains how inefficient
government spending is and he can do
everything better privately in space and
elsewhere
he is
building in tesla a documentedly racist
company uh that perhaps reminds him uh
gives him nostalgic memories of
apartheid south africa where he grew up
that that is a disgusting human being
right there like it is pretty hard i
don't know how the booker the booker
should get a freaking award because to
find a guest who is worse than joy reid
is is a rather extraordinary thing to do
like somebody should get an award can we
send them a cake let's sell them donuts
let's tell them a box of donuts you
found a guest worse than your horrible
host first off the implica okay tesla is
a documentedly racist company that is
the most insane thing yes he's
it's not even worth talking about you
get it this guy is just an idiot then he
tries to link it back to south africa
somehow implying that that elon musk and
his family were somehow for apartheid
like it's just it's just the most awful
worse stuff and also related to all the
tax stuff and everything else uh if elon
musk has broke the law and stiff the
government on taxes the government would
be coming after him now the government
comes after plenty of good people who
aren't worthy of coming after but the
point is if he uses the tax subsidies
that the government allows that doesn't
mean the tax subsidies are good right uh
hate the game not the player right this
was what they were always trying to get
trump on trump did all these things that
are perfectly legal i'm angry at trump
and it's like all right if you don't
like the tax code then change the tax
code i've long argued for a flat tax you
should let's just erase all of the
loopholes erase all of everything figure
out what the tax rates are meaning that
it should be flat for virtually
everybody and if you want to take a
little more from the super rich and let
a few people off the hook at the bottom
so be it but that's it but these people
like that everything that that crazy
person who looks like a villain in
batman
on a show with a psychopath
not good people i don't like these
people
then i said okay there's got to be
something else so then this clip was
going around over the weekend
this is that guy joe scarborough who
used to be kind of saying he went off
the deep end he married his co-host
misha brzezinski and she's sort of nuts
too and i want you to listen to this
this is in 2017
when they're talking about donald trump
and how they're losing the narrative and
this guy basically might start doing
things that they don't like but i want
you to listen to this and think about it
as if it was yesterday and then talking
about
elon musk and i think you're going to
see sort of how this thing operates so
again just to be clear this is 2017
talking about trump but tell me how
different this is then exactly what the
machine wants you to think about elon
musk today who were trump voters
and are still trump supporters they go
yeah you guys are going crazy he's doing
what are you so surprised about he's
doing exactly what he said he's going to
do well and i think that
the dangerous you know edges here are
that he's trying to undermine the media
trying to make up his own facts
and it could be that while unemployment
and
the the economy worsens he could have
undermined the messaging so much that he
can actually control
uh exactly what people think and that is
the that is our job yeah if you look at
the issues uh
yamiche is right he's doing exactly what
he said
did you catch that part please later
rewind it and watch it again we should
have clipped it it's her job to tell you
what's true people it's her job
it can't be somebody else's job it's
their job over at msnbc to tell you what
is true but you see it's the same thing
evil donald trump was undermining the
media elon musk is undermining the media
undermining corporate press undermining
the messaging
scary people undermining the messaging
letting more people talk giving you the
tools and opportunity to fight for
yourself crazy orange man and
rich billionaire with his spaceships but
there's more from msnbc uh here's katie
turner who's uh msnbc hosted she's
freaking out she's freaking
there are real
and devastating consequences for using
that platform
to lie and we've seen it we've seen it
happen
i i wonder
you know when talking about this it's
you know it's kind of funny elon musk
wants to buy it but there are massive
life and globe alter altering
consequences for just letting people run
wild on the thing
yes
she's basically crying saying that more
people might be able to say things what
is she talking about people lie on
twitter every day people lie in real
life every day open up facebook it is a
litany of lies you people are the chief
architects of all of the lies you're not
against lies you're against other people
telling the truth is what you're
actually trying to say these hysterical
children should all be studied and
institutionalized
but it's not just msnbc here's potato
man stelter and he's freaking out too
because you know elon might start
allowing people to think about the
messaging differently he might start
allowing people to get alternate
information he might start uh having it
known that these people are all liars
and con artists this the
questions the the hopes and the fears
that he's going to come in and overhaul
uh twitter's policies let anything go on
twitter and remove some of the rules of
the road you think that's not likely
well i don't know i just think he has to
persuade people it's just he's not king
of twitter he's you know it's he can
he's a board member of 12 board members
and then there's a management staff now
some people might agree with him some
people might not but this is a public
company and so he can't just decree
things he can certainly do it on twitter
and create lots of pressure and a lot of
fun in some ways and some of the ideas
are good and some of the ideas are odd
but that's okay so who cares essentially
that's what
what's interesting about that is the
guest there kara swisher she's a leftist
new york times whack job i'm pretty sure
she's called me racist a couple times on
twitter she actually starting to sound
like the voice of reason there he's not
the king of twitter the guy's trying to
buy it what's interesting also about the
board versus the uh shareholders is that
every single i just want to be very very
clear about this as someone that started
a startup and that eventually we merged
with a bigger company if on any given
day over the past three and a half years
when i was running locals and everyone
who's ever done a startup or anyone
who's ever done a business any business
if you got a call from elon musk and
elon musk was like hey i'd like to buy
your business and i'd like to buy it for
much more than it's worth that is the
greatest day as a business owner you
could possibly have whether you have a
pizza joint an elon musk is like i want
to get into the pizza biz or you have a
tech company
or whatever you have if you got a call
from the richest man in the world who
said i like what you're doing and i'd
like to help it grow
or in this case he's not even saying
it's a functional business he's just
saying i'd like to do something good
with the world that is the greatest
thing that could happen so if you are a
shareholder of twitter right now you
should be on the phone with your lawyer
because they are offering they elon musk
his people are offering way more than
the company is worth and i'm pretty sure
that if you invested in something i'm
not a math magician but uh if if you
were to invest in conor he'll be with
this one you're a bright guy if you were
to invest in something would you want
more or less money from it let's say
three years later
more okay michael
geniuses i'm working with freaking
geniuses here generally you put money
into an investment and then your hope is
that the company is run well and that
the money becomes more valuable and then
you can sell the shares accordingly or
you can keep riding it out sell some
save some etc etc that's what the beauty
of stocks are okay that's what
capitalism and the free exchange of of
goods and value that's what it's all
about so
this the shareholders basically are now
at war with the board the board who has
decided we will not do what is
fiduciarily
best for the company what is financially
best for the company is not something we
are interested in and it makes you
wonder if they're not
in business for business
right and business is all about creating
capital and making money if they're not
in business for business what is twitter
and business for
could they be in the business of
controlling information is that is that
an actual business and then boy there's
a lot of questions that we'd have to ask
after that
um so there's something very interesting
happening that's what i'm trying to tell
you here's more from stelter and he's
freaking out because this might have
something to do with marijuana
twitter's now in a very public fight
with its biggest shareholder who is also
the richest man in the world who of
course is you know the invested in tesla
and so many other companies and he wants
to be invested more in twitter he says
he wants to pay fifty four dollars 20
cents a share to buy up the rest of
twitter that he doesn't have of course
5420 that's 420 that's a code for
marijuana
you know which he very much enjoys so is
this all a troll or is this very real
well it's real enough that he filed with
the sec it's real enough that he's
saying this is my best and final offer
it's real enough that investors are now
wondering what's going to happen if he
pulls out and sells all the shares he
already has it's a huge problem for
twitter right now all right i'm back
with you i took a little bit of a detour
there halfway through that explanation
because it's just so bizarre right i
mean the 420 cody and everything yeah
for the record the only way to watch cnn
is stoned okay i'm not here to push
drugs on any of you but i'm also here
not to tell anyone to watch cnn but
seriously
a little something and and if you stare
into wolf blitzer's beard long enough
you will see something like you can
actually have a religious experience
you should not what you shouldn't watch
cnn either way um but but anyway you see
that it's just not it's just all
nonsense it's all nonsense
but okay dave you're showing us all
these scary videos of these corporate
people and they don't like this man and
they're lying about him and they're very
freaked out but we want solutions dave
we want solutions
elon musk okay so so you don't like to
lose if in this case you are not
successful in you know the board
does not accept your offer you said you
won't go higher is there a plan b
there is
i i think we i think we would like to
hear a little bit about plan
b for another time i think
another time yeah all right
so i don't know what plan b is um but i
can tell you this elon musk getting
involved in this thing this is big and
obviously he had a plan b it's not like
he just made the offer and thought oh
they're going to automatically take the
offer
and if they don't take the offer i'll
just look like the loser he obviously
was planning something there are
alternative pipes being built right now
peter thiel who was the original founder
of paypal which is sort of where this
all started this this internet world
where this all kind of started when then
we could exchange money online i
remember the first time i got on paypal
i had moved into a new apartment i was a
broke comic and i was basically living
in a hallway with a twin size bed
because i had three roommates who they
had a ex it was literally a hallway and
they were like you could sleep on a cot
in essence give us 200 bucks a month or
something like that i said okay how do
we how do i pay you they said pay pallet
i had to sign up for people i could not
believe that you could link an email
address to your bank account
anyway elon musk and peter thiel founded
paypal way back when and uh peter thiel
obviously put money into rumble locals
is involved with rumble like the
alternate pipes are being built so maybe
that paypal mafia as it's called is
going to come together i don't know
maybe i just i honestly have no idea but
like maybe all of the guys who started
this thing 20 years ago are about to
make a big move to go a little bit
further but why does elon musk want to
do all this in case it's not obvious why
well he was asked
well you're a fighter and you you don't
you don't you don't you don't
you don't like to lose and and you you
you are determined that you don't
basically i i mean you are sure i don't
like to lose i'm not sure many people do
um
but the truth matters to me a lot really
like
sort of pathologically it matters to me
truth
it matters
matters a lot to this guy matters a lot
to me and that reminded me of another
video that we showed you a couple months
ago
this is from a guy you may have heard of
dr jordan peterson when he was on tucker
carlson's fox nation show
talking about truth
and why it matters
you make your decisions in life and i
decided when i was very young i'm in my
mid-20s that i was going to say what i
believed and see what happened i talked
to you earlier in the talk about
adventure you know about
the adventure of truth and
i don't think i'm happy about what has
happened and i certainly have dragged my
family through their fair share of well
both hell and and also incomprehensible
opportunity it's expanded our lives in
both directions to a tremendous degree
but it's certainly been an adventure
it's not been dull
and i don't believe that it
i don't believe that it was a mistake
whatever happens as a consequence of
telling the truth is the best thing that
can happen
it doesn't really matter how it looks to
you at the moment or maybe even across
the years because you have to it's it's
a it's a it's an article of faith in
some sense do you believe that reality
is better constituted as a consequence
of truth or falsity
if you believe that reality is best
constituted as a consequence of truth
then you have a responsibility to speak
the truth
so truth matters a lot to elon musk
truth matters a lot to jordan peterson
jordan peterson goes on to say
that it is a matter of faith right it is
a matter of faith meaning that if you
believe in the truth for truth's sake
that's a matter of faith you have to
take a leap of faith to believe that it
you know the idea that you would just
say the truth and that something better
is going to happen
as jordan's saying a lot of bad things
can happen but it will be the best of
all outcomes because you're believing in
truth and trying to put truth in the
world and that is what sets some order
in the world that is a matter of faith
there's probably not a lot of empirical
evidence for that as jordan said his
life was stretched both ways bad and
good through all of the things that he's
done but okay here's elon musk saying i
will fight for truth
there's jordan peterson saying i will
fight for truth i'm trying to fight for
some truth i actually think that uh
after
the the passover easter weekend maybe
that's lodged a little more in you guys
too that a little truth amongst the
nonsense of the modern world and the
people that want to control us maybe it
matters maybe it actually matters i
think that it does am i completely
bananas i think that it does
uh guys it's me monday over at the
reuben report locals community here's
what i put up
these are the npc people i love this npc
meme if you don't if you're not a
memester online you may not know what
that is these characters that you're
seeing there those are known as npc's
non-playable characters these are in
video games when you come across like
just like an automated character who can
only move in certain ways can't think
for themselves can't really do anything
uh just designed by sort of like poor ai
and you just have to get around them
jump on their heads et cetera et cetera
and they're all saying spaceship man bad
these are all blue check twitter npc
spaceship bad bad because you can see
there they've all become part of the
borg it's the group think against the
individual that's what this thing is
really about we've got some comments
before we've got a cold clothes for you
at the end of the show today we've got
some comments from the locals community
casey says when it comes to freedom of
speech where do you draw the line and
who draws the line in the first place
look
the founders laid it out pretty freaking
well they really did they really did you
can say whatever you want with a couple
of restrictions around it direct threat
for violence the most crazy extreme laws
that we have around libel and slander
which is why they're almost never used
you're allowed to say that people are
mean and bad and all sorts of stuff
trust me people say it about me all the
time
but direct threats to violence basically
is it you are allowed to yell fire in a
crowded theater just not with the intent
to do harm uh there are all sorts of of
things that you are allowed to say and
should be allowed to say the first
amendment has nothing to do with
misinformation or disinformation and if
it did joe biden would be in gulag 36a
because here is the same guy who just
back in june told us if you get the
vaccine you will not get nor transmit
kohit dragonhawk says fauci is a fascist
why do people talk to this clown
because once they're in once you've been
part of the lies for so long all of
these corporate people it just sucks too
because it's like man i just wish you
guys were better that that's the irony
the clip up top that elon was saying
you know in essence he's saying we need
truth we need some sense-making we need
we need some trusted institutions but
none of them work anymore and if some of
them
worked then we wouldn't be in this
situation but once these people have
gone in so deep you've treated fauci
like a king right beyond a king you've
treated him like a god
you can't start backing out and going oh
god bad you just very rarely can do that
and become an apostate to that cult
which also you could liken the reverse
of that all of the people who decided
that their whole world view was based on
what trump was right
which is what i said about a lot of the
atheists like you don't believe in god
but you believe that trump is the devil
if you think that he's the devil well
then every time he makes a decision
you're going to make the opposite
decision but that's no way to live
that's no way to to live life that's no
way to make your decisions right but a
lot of people have done that
margot says is this the last day of your
show for a while dave because of the
tour
okay so that's a good question and i
should address some of that stuff so we
are hitting the road so uh no first off
tomorrow
i will be in studio because the show is
in west palm beach so i'm going to be in
studio tomorrow and then i head up to
west palm
and then i start traveling so the day
after that i'm in clearwater that i'm in
raleigh north carolina as you can see
day after that i'm in atlanta georgia uh
then day after that i'm in chicago
illinois so it's five shows in a row oh
no six shows in a row then we got dallas
texas seven shows in a row washington dc
man i am gonna be z
well eight west niacc new york okay so
we got eight nights in a row it's going
to be crazy so yes i will not be in
studio for a little bit i will miss you
too thank you i appreciate it but i'll
be out there with the people with the
one second hug and all that
pretty much all the vip tickets are sold
out so i don't know how many more hugs i
can be given we've got general admission
tickets at some of the shows still
remaining but i'm seriously psyched to
get out there oh by the way i think i
mentioned this on friday but facebook
completely banned us from the ability to
put ads on instagram or facebook related
to the tour because what was the line
they said i might influence public
opinion
i'm a very scary person and you know i
get up there and who knows what i'm
gonna say i may not do manufactured
talking points like uh the mental
institution of msnbc or the loony bin of
cnn and i get up there and uh it's
loosely scripted and that i don't have a
script i just have a couple thoughts
rattling in my brain and i get out there
and i talk to you guys and q a and my
guests and all that i might influence
public opinion so we could not put any
ads on this tour which is absolutely
ridiculous but that's the way they're
doing it with us so we're pushing it out
and i hope to see you guys uh you know
one of the interesting things our tour
managers have been telling us that
people's buying habits related to covid
people are still if you want to think of
like long-term
ways that kovid changed us people's
buying habits were in the old days you
would buy tickets for things months
before
now people are just buying things
basically day of because they're so
worried that things are going to get
canceled and people money money is tight
and all sorts of stuff by the way if
you're struggling financially or if you
were
a veteran or something like email us
i'll figure out a way to get you to the
show i'll do as much of that as i can
there's a limited amount of seats but i
don't want anyone to feel like they
can't come for financial reasons or if
you've helped out this country i will do
what i can for you daverubin.com
events but all of that to say
we've got some compilations that we're
putting up i've got new interviews that
we've stocked up and the live dms will
resume on may 2nd so
stick around hang tight i'm not
disappearing i'll do some stuff from the
road michael you're coming with me
aren't you you have a phone is that
phone connected to the internet there
michael will take video
of me doing things
maybe eating a meal maybe doing a show
who knows what we're going to do
anything's possible
guys my full interview with michael
knowles he interviewed me on my show
about my book you could almost puke uh
is up right now on youtube and rumble
and on locals again the tickets are
available at daverubin.com
events and
in a final cold close today i think this
is a nice summation of where we're at in
the post-woke
world
you know there are american heroes
who don't like this idea
neil armstrong gene cernan have both
testified against commercial space
flight and the way that you're
developing it and i wonder what you
think of that
i was very sad to see that um because
those guys are
yeah you know those guys are heroes of
mine so it's really tough
you know i i wish they would come and
visit and and see the hardware that
we're doing here
and i think that would change their mind
they inspired you to do this didn't they
yes
and to see them casting stones in your
direction
it's difficult
did you expect them to cheer you on
so they're hoping they would
did you think
i need to pack this in never
why not
i don't ever give up
i mean i'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated
you